boa tarde pessoal
o meu nome s
x eu sou
era da computação e chocou o fundador de
uma escola chamada repicou hoje a rep
code é uma escola de programação pra
crianças e adolescentes a partir de 6
anos
analice nama ou ciência da computação
para crianças nessa idade porque nós
acreditamos nisso que steve jobs já dia
lá em 95 que todos independente da idade
ou da profissão que queiram seguir
quero trilhar no futuro seja médico seja
advogado deve aprender a programar
porque nos ensina a pensar o nosso foco
na escola não é formado desenvolvedores
de software forma crianças que vão sê
engenheiros no futuro não mas sim fazer
com que eles desenvolvam a habilidade e
o ensino da programação pode
proporcionar
é que eles estejam mais preparados para
um futuro que vão encontrar na frente
como já disseram aqui hoje é a tendência
que até 2020
praticamente todas as profissões têm um
envolvimento com o mundo digital e eu
comecei a sentir na pele os benefícios
do programa quando tinha 12 anos foi
logo que eu tiver acesso à internet pela
primeira vez há dois anos depois que
ganhei meu computador
naquela época a mania entre os jovens da
unidade era lugar né a todos os jovens
da minha idade que tinha um blog agente
utilizava como diária a gente e
expressava compartilhar as coisas do dia
a dia era o nosso lep chat da época e eu
me incomodava né com a questão dos blogs
serem aquelas coisas personalizarem
aquelas coisas padronizados aqueles
template's
pronto e tudo mais eu queria ter meu
próprio tempo e aqui o blog estivessem a
akira que o meu blog que tivesse a minha
cara refletir a minha personalidade e aí
eu comecei a me aprofundar nesse link
querer saber como fazer pra que é um
template a minha casa foi que eu comecei
a aprender sobre criação do site sobre
html e tudo mais e eu comecei a vender
template precisamente queriam os blogs
deles personalizados também então foi é
interessante ou com 12 anos começando a
ganhar dinheiro com programação era um
dinheiro legal para uma criança de 12
anos eu conseguia pagar o lanche na
cantina e ainda ir para o mac donald's
ia pagar o próprio mec donas e eu queria
me aprofundar naquilo que queria ir mais
fundo
então eu comecei a procurar pessoas que
pudessem me ensinar mais sobre aquilo
que pudessem é uma escola que pudesse
vir me ensinar a criar sites
procurei cursos de webdesign mas todos
que encontrei lá em 2012
eram pessoas a partir de 15 anos e acho
que você não tivesse encontrado uma uma
escola que me ensinasse isso meus pais
muito provavelmente não teriam
estimulado a continuar nesse porque
naquele momento era mais importante para
meus pais muito por não enxergar que ele
poderia ser uma coisa promissora
independente do que eu escolhesse dali
pra frente
era importante para eles eu aprendesse
inglês porque inglês era uma habilidade
básica necessária para que eu pudesse
arrumam o emprego e começassem uma
carreira promissora ao longo do tempo é
sempre houve na habilidades básicas
necessárias para que o indivíduo se
destacasse demais e até mesmo
conforme isso ea crescendo e se tornando
mais popular para não ficar pra trás
foi assim com a matemática foi assim com
a leitura e com a escrita
na época os meus bisavós dos meus avós
ler e escrever um diferencial
foi assim com a datilografia quando
surgir as máquinas de escrever né
acho que todo mundo aqui já ouviu a
frase na minha época quem não fizer esse
curso de datilografia não arrumava
emprego
foi assim com o inglês
na minha época né o inglês ainda é uma
habilidade extremamente necessária pra
gente viver nesse mundo globalizado né
pra poder se comunicar com pessoas do
mundo inteiro uma forma única
a informática né quando o computador
surgiu e fez com que a gente utilizasse
ele como ferramenta no dia-a-dia
precisamos aprender a usá eles
precisamos nos tornar excelentes
usuários
porém isso já não é mais suficiente a
gente precisa deixar de ser bons
usuários de computador pra começar a
criar soluções utilizando a tecnologia
né então é a gente precisa aprender a
programar a ensinar essa geração que
está vindo aí a programar porque essa
geração já nasceu conectada já desde
pequenos já estão acostumados a usar o
smartphone a usá tablets e ver crianças
muito pequenas que não têm muita noção
do do mundo ainda pegando revistas
impressas e fazendo um movimento de
chope pra mudar foto e elas já sabem
utilizar é a tecnologia uma forma básica
porém elas precisam se preparar para
deixar de ser usuário de começar a criar
tecnologia e além de poder criar
tecnologia aprender a programar também
desenvolve habilidades são fundamentais
para a vida e fazem com que as crianças
possam crescer e se tornar adultos mas
pronto
o mundo em que a gente vive é mais
humanos inclusive uma das das
habilidades é a compreensão da
tecnologia aprendendo a programar as
crianças podem compreender melhor a
tecnologia compreender melhor como
aquilo que elas já estão acostumados a
usar foi feito como aquilo funciona e
como utilizar isso com mais consciência
né com mais sabedoria e desenvolve
também o pensamento lógico né pra criar
um programa de computador mais simples
que ele seja ele precisa ser pensada de
forma lógica e hoje em dia há a algumas
pessoas têm dificuldade com relações
lógicas com questões simples de lógica e
tudo mais
ele pode ser desenvolvido facilmente com
programação é a superação de desafios
também é uma coisa interessante pra
gente
programar muitas vezes a gente acaba
encontrando desafios e precisa encontrar
soluções para poder transpor esses
desafios e ensinar programar a encontrar
esses desafios ensina para as crianças
se elas não fizerem nada elas não vão
conseguir transpor esses desafios nada
vai acontecer
elas precisam pensar em soluções pra
isso e isso faz com que ela desenvolveu
também a criatividade o pensamento
criativo é uma coisa necessária também
para o futuro nem sempre é a solução que
é elas pensaram vai ser a melhor
possível
muitas vezes elas vão enxergar também
que o colega ali do lado que está
tentando solucionar um problema ela pode
ajudar ele e ela começa a perceber que
trabalhar em equipe pode ser uma coisa
legal pode ser positivo que chu pode
fazer com que todos avancem compartilhar
é muito importante isso
compartilhar idéias o raciocínio lógico
a compreensão da tecnologia faz com que
as crianças sejam muito mais confiantes
que elas se sintam prontas pra enfrentar
as coisas é que elas se relacionam mais
com os outros e isso pode trazer uma
independência para essas crianças de uma
forma mais fácil que elas não sejam é
tão dependente né pra aprender as coisas
que elas buscam pra encontrar soluções
para seus problemas seja pra poder
personalizar um blog e oprah poder enfim
quantas pessoas eles não conhecem hoje
né que tem uma ideia legal de aplicativo
uma idéia que pode solucionar um
problema só que falta um pouco de
conhecimento de compreensão da
tecnologia
a longo prazo essa independência de
alguém que conheça a tecnologia pode ser
adquirida para poder solucionar algum
problema importante para os outros
outra coisa importante que as crianças
aprendem programando é aprender com os
erros delas é quando a gente está
programando muitas vezes a gente é
alguma coisa testa não funciona então a
gente cometeu algum erro a gente volta a
enxergar onde foi que a gente ro e corri
e segue em frente
e isso é importante para as crianças
porque elas aprendem a errada maneira
certa que é tentando acertar e
aprendendo com os erros
a questão da perseverança né as crianças
nesse nesse ciclo de implementar uma
idéia é testar e ver que não deu certo e
experimentar de novo buscar novas
tecnologias buscar ajuda
tudo isso acaba desenvolvendo a
perseverança neles e eles acabam
percebendo que muitas vezes nem
solucionar um problema só questão de
perseverança só questão de não desistir
e à capacidade de solução do problema
deles também aumenta muito né eles não
passam a não ficar esperando que esse
problema se resolva sozinho eles começam
a ter mais atitude também a capacidade
deles de poder pegar um problema grande
e decompor em problemas menores em
soluções mais fáceis e resolver assim
coisas que você olha e fala caramba
criança consiga resolver isso é ilegal e
é aí que vem essa sensação de realização
das crianças de ela se sentir em que
elas têm o poder de poder tirar a idéia
delas na cabeça e de fazer isso
acontecer de tornar isso real de fazer
com que as pessoas vejam experimentem ao
resultado da ideia delas
esse é o momento que eu falo que as
crianças aprendem que elas têm poderes
mágicos né de tornar real que ela
imagina e é legal também que elas
percebem que o mundo ainda não está
pronto que nem tudo foi inventado que
elas podem melhorar muito esse mundo e
que elas têm a capacidade tem o
conhecimento de poder tornar esse mundo
um lugar melhor e eu queria deixar aqui
pra vocês dois
a certeza de que nós vamos viver num
mundo melhor nossos filhos vão viver num
mundo melhor
muito provavelmente criado pelas
próprias mãos deles
muito obrigado